just one word why carry is directed by
kimberly peirce and stars Chloe grace
Moretz and Julianne Moore this is a
reimagining of the Stephen King book as
the opening credits tells us officially
on paper this is not a remake of the
original film from the 70s now Carrie is
not popular in fact she is the very
definition of unpopular people pick on
her all the time there are very few
people at her school who actually like
her most of the people on her side are
actually just teachers and so that's
kind of sad now her mother played by
Julianne Moore is extremely religious
very much so to the point of almost
everything is a sin to this woman if you
do something wrong you're gonna get
locked in the closet you gotta pray all
night
so basically Carrie has a horrible life
and when she figures out that she is in
fact Jean Grey from x-men she decides to
use these newfound telekinetic powers
for her own benefit so as I said in the
beginning this review technically this
film is not remake it is based off of
the Stephen King novel but I was
thinking on the way home really what is
the purpose of this movie ask yourself
this question are we as a society of
film goers so desensitized to the fact
that remakes are inevitable that they
are everywhere and they're going to be
many more of them that we have grown to
just accept them because really what is
the purpose of this remake is it to give
justice to the original book by Stephen
King because the original film did not
do that
no because the original film is actually
a classic and well regarded by many
people and still watch today and it
still holds up today and it's a good
movie that did justice to Stephen King's
book so what really is the purpose of
remaking the exact same material and the
only thing that is different in it is
the initial big bully attack is filmed
on a cell phone and spread through
social media outlets everything else is
the exact same so what really is the
purpose of remaking this movie honestly
there's no reason to remake Carey it was
good really good
the only reason to go back and remake it
is to get people who never saw the
original get the modern audiences in
there see some remake
you're like okay they did something
different they improved upon the
original or they made it closer to the
source material and okay I get why they
remade that movie this movie kind of
reminds me of psycho the 1998 version
Vince Vaughn and Gus Van Sant remade
psycho for absolutely no reason and it
was essentially a shot-for-shot remake
and it's like why there's no reason to
remake psycho it's freakin psycho
there's no reason to remake Carrey and
yet we have Carrey 2013 version okay
rant over is this a terrible movie no
it's not it has some good elements to it
that revenge scene that we all know is
coming because of all the posters and
all the images released that we all know
what's going to happen it's still
satisfying to watch there are a moment
to this movie where you're like okay
that was pretty cool there's some okay
performances in it there's some good
scenes in it it's not terribly directed
but it is painfully unnecessary and as
you watch the movie you know each thing
that's gonna happen some elements of it
were very CGI
s like certain final destination style
deaths that felt out of place it's not a
terribly made film and after my rant
you're gonna be like wow he hates this
movie but I really just hate the fact
that this movie exists the revenge scene
though was pretty cool and well handled
there are just certain elements to this
movie that actually worked but for the
most part you're watching this movie
just thinking there really is no reason
to be here right now I don't really see
the point of this movie you can go see
it if you want to it's not an awful
movie but I really just think it's a
parlous movie I'm gonna give Carey a cc4
Carey dump on the night as always guys
thanks very much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]